[Musique]
avec vous hélène frade bonjour hélène
bonjour
moi de même vous m'avez manqué hier à la
une de la presse la rencontre entre
vladimir poutine emmanuel macron on en
parlait à l'instant avec damien coq et
dans le contexte de tension évidemment
un grandissante autour de l'ukraine mc
on cherche à éviter la guerre d'après le
financial times des responsables
français assure que vladimir poutine
s'est engagé à l'issue de cette
rencontre à s'engager donc dans la
désescalade de la crise eux craignent n
en promettant entre autres de ne pas
entreprendre de nouvelles initiatives
militaires je cite cette déclarations
d'apaisement pauline tranche avec la
distance entre les deux dirigeants au
kremlin où emmanuel macron et vladimir
poutine étaient séparés par une table de
5 m une table presque aussi grande que
la distance qui sépare aujourd'hui
moscou et l'otan selon le quotidien
espagnol el país quelles réactions en
france et en russie à la une du journal
kommersant la table a été raccourcie
creek mais la tonalité reste assez peu
amènes puisque le quotidien évoque je
cite le variant au maquereau qui aurait
tenté d' infecté vladimir poutine de le
rallier à ses positions dans l'ensemble
est à l'image du kremlin d'ailleurs
commerçante souffle le chaud et le froid
emmanuel macron espérait récolter les
lauriers de sauveur de l'europe et blé
d'hiver poutine a clairement indiqué
qu'il considérait que le président
français pouvaient être tenir ce rôle
commente le quotidien avec magnanimité à
défaut de formule magique pour sortir de
l'impasse tout au plus peut-on espérer
une formulation magique dont les
ambiguïtés permettent de gagner un peu
de temps en france le figaro ne se fait
pas d'illusions et dit espérer qu
emmanuel macron aura été instruit de ce
proverbe russe si tu invites un autre un
ours à danser ce n'est pas toi qui
décide quand la danse est finie c'est
l'ours son folklore à chacun ses
références à la une de libération la
fameuse table est aussi longue que
sinueuse comme un serpent et le journal
annonce est bien qu emmanuel macron a
débuté sa campagne de russie allusion on
aventures de napoléon comme à la
campagne pour la présidentielle avec un
président candidat officieux à sa
réélection à vie en avril qui
chercherait à renforcer sa stature
internationale
emmanuel macron et vladimir poutine qu
on retrouve tous les deux dans ce
dessein de steve bell pour deux
gardiennes se pinçant mutuellement les
tétons comme dans le tableau montrant
gabrielle d'estrées la favorite d'henri
iv et sa soeur un tableau à la fois
érotique est ambiguë leur mouvement a eu
pour le coup et sans ambiguïté hélène au
canada les camionneurs hostile à la
nouvelle loi sur l'obligation vaccinale
contre le coc u19 paralyse toujours la
capitale fédérale canadienne ottawa le
blocage de la ville par l'auto proclamé
freedom convoy le convoi de la liberté a
amené le maire de la capitale fédérale a
décrété l'état d'urgence dimanche le
maire d'ottawa la police de la ville et
le premier ministre canadien justin
trudeau que de national post accuse
d'être eux-mêmes responsable de ce
blocage d'ottawa pour avoir parié à tort
sur un essoufflement rapide du mouvement
loin de s'essouffler dernier chercherait
à faire tâche d'huile selon le quotidien
américain de new york times qui rapporte
que les manifestations de tahoua sont
devenus un cri de ralliement pour les
puissants groupes d'extrême droite et
anti vaccins du monde entier notamment
en allemagne aux pays-bas et en belgique
en france le monde fait état d'un projet
de mobilisation autour de paris le 13
février prochain sur le modèle des
camionneurs canadien le journal parle
d'une initiative qui rappelle les gilet
jaune a paru fin 2018 avec déjà plus de
250 mille internautes ont rallié sur
facebook en france c'est la réforme dans
la réforme le ministre de l'éducation
jean michel blanquer rétropédale sur une
mesure controversée de sa réforme du bac
et se dit prêt à réintroduire les maths
dans le tronc commun au lycée depuis
leur disparition du tronc commun en 2019
le nombre d'élèves exposé à
l'enseignement des maths est en chute
libre seulement 37% dans la dernière
année lycéens selon le figaro la croix
s'inquiète de cette désaffection qu'ils
jugent préoccupante quand il apparaît
difficile de comprendre le monde de
partager des diagnostics chiffre est
sans un bagage mathématiques minimale
comme lorsqu'on parle de taux
d'incidence en santé publique inquiétude
aussi parce que le fameux esprit
français serait dit-on un alliage de
finesse et de géométrie d'après les
statistiques de l'éducation nationale le
recul des matches serait encore plus
marquée pauline chez les filles se sont
largement détournés de cette matière ces
trois dernières années d'où ce dessin de
coco une mère de famille croulant sous
les tâches domestiques dit que les maths
au lycée c'était pas son truc et que
c'est plus tard qu'elle s'est mise aux
équations difficile ça vous dit
peut-être quelque chose pas du tout non
merci beaucoup et l'aisne